Hey, this may or may not surprise some of you.
Yet another Republican has been found guilty of
voter fraud. And, you know, I saw the headline,
Former New York election official pleads Guilty
to Ballot Fraud. I knew it was going to be
a Republican, but I figured I should look at
the article just to make sure. And of course, it
was Jason Show Field, a Republican who recently
resigned from the Rensselaer County Board of
Elections in New York, admitted he applied
for absentee ballots using other people's
per other voter's personal information.
He pleaded guilty yesterday to applying for
absentee ballots in the names of others. He's
from Troy, New York. He resigned late last month
and he admits back in 2021, he unlawfully used the
names and birthdates of voters in connection
with 12 absentee ballot applications that he
electronically submitted to the New York State
voter absentee ballot application request,
Portal portal. He's 43 years old. He admits
he falsely certified that he was those 12
different people. He was originally arraigned in
September. His attorney said Scofield maintained
his innocence in the 12 count indictment. He's
scheduled to be sentenced May 12th. He faces
up to five years in prison, a fine of a quarter
million dollars and supervised release of up to
three years for each count. The really important
take away here continues to be individual voter
fraud of this kind is very, very rare in the
United States. There's a study by the Brennan
Center for Justice. Voter fraud occurs at a rate
of less than 0.0003%. That's like one case of
fraud for every 30 million votes that are cast.
And other studies have found the same. However,
when we do find stories of individual voter
fraud, aside from being really rare, they are
mostly Republicans. And it's a really terrible way
to try to win elections. And the reason is that
the scale is so small and the risk so big. Voter
fraud of this kind often involves one or a few
people trying to sway the outcome of an election,
at least in theory. And even if they get away with
their small scale voter fraud, the impact on the
overall results would rarely be significant. Now,
if it's a really, really, really tiny election,
you know, a town of 800 people in which only a
fraction are adults and only a fraction vote, and
it could come down to five votes. And you do this
with 12 ballots, maybe you can swing an election.
Insanely unlikely, and the risk is too high.
They love to say we have no way of catching these
people. We seem to catch plenty of them. And they
almost exclusively are Republicans who are either
trying to test the system or are saying it's
actually Democrats who are doing it. So another
case, relatively rare, but it just so happens
that it's yet another Republican sentencing in
May. We'll see if they throw the book at him,
which would mean five years. And that would
be pretty interesting to see, I must say.